and all of a sudden this dude comes by
he's got the [__] selfie stick go
away remember when everyone was getting
him okay it was annoying but how about
that there's still people that have
those
and use them and they are an Asian
you want to talk about for some reason
if you see an Asian with any sort of
electron electronic or fashion you kind
of just give them a pass you're like
you're gonna oh well you know they're
[__] they're from way far away so
really it's almost like they they're on
like like any place that's really far
away
like Mexico no Canada absolutely not
you you know London no a little bit if
you meet somebody like oh no that's a
cow and he's got like orange goggles on
you're like okay
but Japan India Asia Russia you know I'm
talking about you see a Russian dude
with like a just like a big like Tommy
Hilfiger cape on and you're like I don't
know I guess they wear those over there
it gets cold
but like or or a Japanese guy with like
all leather and a leather hat with a
leather horn on it and he's got like
Google Glasses and you say you know I I
don't know I guess
he's really small and thin and wavy like
what else is he gonna do but dude I
straight up just saw a Mexican dude with
a selfie stick like that's crazy to me
to see a Mexican dude with a selfie
stick just like a portly dude he wasn't
even doing it like this like
he was just walking down the street like
you ever see someone walking on the
street and you're like where's your car
though
what I'm talking about like did you park
and you're and walking or like well he
wasn't shopping just dude walking around
with a selfie stick and I'm sure he was
from La like it wasn't a tourist thing
so he was walking around with a selfie
stick
and this is the worst part okay well
actually there's two worst Parts he was
holding it on his belly so it was like
resting on his belly poking out from his
belly like a piece of lazy [__] okay and
and sauntering around
the only Mexican dude with a a [__]
selfie stick within a 50 mile race
radius and we're in La so Mexican dudes
are a plenty
and he's just holding it chilling it off
with it on his pot belly
and this is the worst part one of the
other worst parts
the camera was facing outward so
he's not even doing what a selfie stick
is supposed to be used for it's called
the selfie stick because it's supposed
to be shooting you
I thought maybe he had a [__] you
know some stupid internet show where
he's just like lol you know hey welcome
dog this is [__]
you know
Melrose weekly we going on Melrose and
see what the [__] guys jumps by and
on [__] Mother's Day dog
got five bouquets man try to [__] act
like he didn't get five bouquets man got
for three bouquets I had to go in anyway
man anyway what's your name you know
so so he's it's a point outwards and uh
and and he doesn't see me and and he
doesn't see me and I'm like okay well he
doesn't see me so that's good but now
I'm gauging is the guy gonna recognize
me or not because if if he recognizes me
um cooked right because it's just gonna
be on me okay
so I'm just kind of drinking my [__] to
myself right because also the other time
when someone's videoing me I can't be
like don't video me
because then people are gonna be like oh
crystalline was a piece of [__] he
yelled at someone that's assault he
doesn't see me but what he is doing is
recording a a [__] two a couple and
another woman are together it's like a
third wheel thing there's a couple and
then another woman
and he's just like this he's just like
this drinking something just like this
selfie stick extended [__] ass selfies
imagine going like this
so he's doing it and it's like a minute
passes and the the one of the ladies
takes the menu
and she's just like kind of blocking it
and then other guy's doing it like this
and they're not saying anything I want
to say something because you know me
dude Johnny confrontation right but I'm
also like ah it's on video
could be live all of a sudden crystalia
you know but he's also not shooting me
but in a way I want to be like a you
know because I've been watching that
show Titan from HBO Max and I'm like
dude I'm kind of like that a superhero
so I kind of want to save these people
right like I'm a little bit like
Nightwing in a way so I'm like okay I
don't say anything and then the lady
from the thing from that's getting
recorded looks at me at laughing like
what's this guy doing and when she does
that
he swings it over to me
lady
know the game
okay hey lady
I'm not a part of this
now he got me involved so now
pissed now God deal with this crazy dude
okay
swings it over to me
now he's filming me
and I get up
and walk over to him
because Johnny confrontation baby
but he's still recording he backs up a
little bit like what's this guy gonna do
still recording and I like sidestep and
I look at his screen on his phone
because I'm like I want to know a
hundred percent if he's recording sure
enough he's recording and he looks at me
and says hey bro what's your problem
dude when I tell you
just heat just the my blood just
immediately
ding it's done kurdlin okay my inside my
body blood in my veins curdling dude I
want it to be like oh dude
congratulations man you made my blood
curdle that's so awesome for you dude
but I didn't say [__] because I don't
want him to record me so I just leave
and I left coffee early and he [__]
won I guess he won dude
yay dude thank you for winning you know
what man this is the [__] God damn it
[__] the the the it's the thing with the
because we gotta here's the thing that
guy
deserves
eveled all right
he deserves to get smacked in his lip
whoops said it
but he does the guy deserves to get a
nice [__] Tom Hanks Pap or what was
the or the Burt Reynolds slap that's
what he deserves to get just a nice Burt
Reynolds pep right in his hey well
that's what you get right instead he
deserves a nice Burt Reynolds 80s pop
right in his lip to where not not too
much damage but where he just goes like
did I did something and it's and then he
wakes up the next day and it's actually
fine
you know like that's what he deserves oh
[__] did he [__] and then no
this is the thing man so now because he
could put it online so everyone's gonna
be on their best goddamn Behavior even
if somebody's being a [__] right
and then part of me is like should I
tell the establishment but I'm not a
[__] tattletale I deal with my [__]
on my lonely
I deal with my [__] by my lonely
everybody knows about Delia Delia who's
that the guy who deals with this [__] by
his lonely okay fine yeah all right well
then he's not gonna tattle I don't
tattle dude I don't [__] tattle bro
[Music]
crazy
you're crazy congratulations